a puertas de convertirse en ley el
aborto libre en argentina está en manos
del senado el proyecto de ley que
plantea que se permita interrumpir el
embarazo hasta la semana 14 ya fue
aprobado por la cámara de diputados- y
este martes cerca de 70 senadores
deciden sobre el proyecto de ley que
lleva a la firma del presidente alberto
fernández los de si o verdes aseguran
que la penalización hace que miles de
mujeres mueran al llevar a cabo abortos
clandestinos tenemos el derecho a poder
decidir sobre nuestros proyectos de vida
sobre si queremos o no queremos tener
hijos y de querer tenerlo cuanto
queremos tener y si decidimos
interrumpir el embarazo que lo podamos
hacer de manera autónoma y libre sobre
nuestros cuerpos y vidas los del no los
celestes se fundamentan en que el feto
ya es una vida que descartemos a
nuestros hijos porque si por meros
deseos pudiendo nos hacernos cargo
pudiendo afrontar digamos y llevar
adelante ese embarazo es la necesidad de
legislar por deseos por deseos yo te
deseo y sos una persona yo no te deseo y
por arte de magia dejaste de ser una
persona y te puedo desechar ya mí esto
me parece gravísimo en el año 2018 el
proyecto de ley de la intervención del
embarazo se quedó estancado en el senado
de llegar a un empate la encargada de
decidir es la actual vicepresidenta
cristina fernández de kirchner quien
está a favor del proyecto con presiones
de la iglesia y otros colectivos
sociales el congreso será una vez más
sede de manifestaciones se estima que en
la nación suramericana se realizan más
de 300.000 abortos clandestinos al año
decenas de mujeres mueren durante el
procedimiento que en argentina sólo es
legal cuando la vida salud física y
mental de la madre está en peligro o
cuando el embarazo es producto de una
violación